hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to inscription i'm on
my fourth playthrough and i know that
i'm not anywhere near to the end of this
and i know that i can get that underway
because i have the cards that i need to
do that unless i'm wrong about what that
is so i might be who knows
whatever i always like having wolves
it is kind of the same strategy i always
do though i don't really have many one
card things but i do love the wolves
plus if i can merge them together that'd
be even better
i don't need items i always could do
with the power up
yeah let's do that
i do eventually need uh totem i don't
have that ooh
the hearts oh no way well
you could
you could actually this guy's been
saying no way for a while i'm just kind
of curious what does happen
yeah maybe i i think in the next few if
i want to find out what exactly is
happening here i have to discover like
what's the deal with the stoat and they
said that one more thing was around i
just don't know what that is also i've i
don't have my totem anymore my amazing
incredible totem well this is why you
have a lot of health beau
oh man it's really gonna suck without
those squirrels man i was really like my
whole life
my whole life with those squirrels this
is so sad
oh
and there's having this whirls
can i have a totem
can i have a totem what do i even have
oh i got my two wolves that i can't blah
actually
[Music]
not enough buddy
not enough
and my stink bug which i could play
definitely
shall we we shall
easy peasy
all right i'm gonna go for the totem
just because i like the idea of having
one
period hey gold man i'll be darned you
came across me early
care for a game of chance if you pick a
boulder and if it's gold
middle
dagnabbit no gold
but that's a funny look environment
keep it okay thank you
corpseter if a creature that you own
perishes by combat a card bearing the
sigil in your hand is automatically
played in its place well that's nice so
i just need to keep that in my hand i
never actually need to play it
or whatever thank you dude
thank you brew
thank you bro haim
ah squirrels uh-huh okay
ah
damn not
exactly what i was looking for i'll go
for the wolf head just in case there's
anything it's not like my squirrels
with flying defense is gonna do me any
good all right i'll just get the whole
fed just in case ah thank you
all right
all right spay your rules
spyros
[Music]
okay when that dies it'll be replaced by
corpse maggots with
fly protection which is
what i want
definitely
damn all your flying creatures i don't
have anything about that
man i really don't have a lot
i'm kind of in a bit of a
predicament
ah see corpses are in no short supply
oh
man this uh this round ain't doing
nearly as good as i had hoped it would
um
yeah drock cardi right you're right
let's stinkbug this guy
because that makes it so there's
basically nothing there
[Music]
yeah
i do want to get some damage in
does that make sense i don't know
oh it can hit it even if it's flying
okay it can't oh wait a minute i for i
should have done the wolf on the ah
okay well look man i'm i don't have my
infinite squirrels i'm kind of not doing
as good
kaminsky
the black good if i can't win this one i
will definitely try to play
the
thingamabobber
the thingamabobber because i bet that's
it
come on ah damn it all right whatever
let's try to do this at least it's
something for the squirrel
damn it uh squirrel having a pack though
that is kind of fun
that's kind of fun
that's kind of fun ooh
greetings yes greetings
i'm using that just because i want to
see what happens when it give ooh bones
well that's nice
bad place shut up
shut up you loser you're a bad play
whoa
masterful i know
i know
it's going to make complete sense why i
did that
that's oh i forgot i moved
oh it's not nearly as good as i thought
it'd be
that stings it sure do
wolf
i actually have to do some sacrificing
it's not actually just gonna all be easy
for me i get that
oh
that didn't work out so good for you ow
well that didn't work out so good for
you huh
my other wolf damn it
well it's all good okay
we're back in the swing of things we're
back in the swing of things we're
getting back to it we're getting back to
it don't you worry don't you worry
uh the beehive right
the beehive is a nice idea kind of like
that
but it has to be hit
which is kind of the problem
not exactly the best thing but it is
something
oh come on
oh come on
all right fine bugs i'm still going with
the squirrel pack i'm not even gonna
make it past the first round and i still
haven't done my black goat play because
i don't even know where my black goat
has been
i know i know i know i know i know i
know
i know i'm so sick of this boss
shut up i'm in my immersion you're
ruining my amur
oh [ __ ]
god damn it i don't have
what does this do
okay this is good
i'm gonna skip you
god damn it does it is it a problem if
that boulder's there i don't know i'm
gonna have to try it i'm literally
you'll pass your next turn of course you
will because i'm gonna skip this one
you're obligated to pass that's fine the
reason i'm doing this is because i need
to draw another one of these
and i'm going to place it here so that i
can
[Music]
play this
here
and then play that there
did you hear that it did something it
did something it did something hell yes
it did something okay so with the other
thing that i need to do is i need to
make sure that i absolutely kill that
freaking
pack mule when it comes out
and beehive
did i just get another one of those
no whatever
b i only got one b out of that well
that's that's hardly good what i want to
do actually is i kind of want to keep
that there because i need to hit this
for two turns
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
put the b
because i need to draw don't i
[Music]
bullfrog interesting so if i put that
there it'll just die which is not what i
want i want to kill that wolf cub and
then i want that coyote to stay there
that's what i want
perfect
i can take that that's a hit i can take
because now
i'm going to draw
one of these and you just go ahead and
skip your turn because i wonder if
that's going to negate his whole
when this is all done kind of thing
that there
and this uh
there
put that there perfect now watch this
move
perfect perfect
oh you love to see it dagnabbit
yeah you deserve that
pass
yes you do pass
yes you do oh wait no i thought that
would have been enough damage uh never
mind i'm dumb i didn't need to do that
that was not what i was intending wait
mirror
mirror what does that mean
i'll save it let's go ahead and pull
another
boss time eh you know it baby
yeah oh it doesn't hit the wolf cub but
god damn it i
meant to hit the wolf cub
there's goldie in your cards here sure
is
thanks buddy thanks buddy you struck
gold you sure did good job
i can't do anything
okay easy easy peasy
okay stink bug that's good i don't know
what this means i can't read it it's all
squibbled up
only one way to find out
[Music]
two dude i don't know what that means
i don't know why it's two
let's go ahead and just play this
this will do for
now perfect good this is all good this
is all great sure wish i had more space
but it's fine
nice all right let's go with that
two oh it's it mirrors the ah of course
it's a mirror it mirrors the attack of
the thing next to it so it's useless
unless it's up against something tough
interesting
okay got it got it got it got it got it
okay this is what we're gonna do
perfect
done easy
easy peasy
what happens if you stink them
good play stink it up you can't do
nothing
well i guess it didn't matter anyway
because you were gonna be dead all right
i win my hand is a lot more complicated
than it was before with all my rulies
and all that but i'm still winning
reignite thank you
thank you thank you for that
all right what have you got
no that's a good card
poor abandoned child it does not die
when sacrificed
do you have the heart to try what the
hell i do love those infinite sacrifice
things but why is it special why is it
any different than the cat it's gotta be
different there's gotta be something
different about it right
it's gotta be i think okay now i gotta
go check the thing on the wall because i
definitely solved it a moment
i definitely solved it whoa what the
frick
is that like two cost cars oh what is
that
oh what
what
have you seen my pot of plant
oh you plucked that from the oil
painting
you must not like the cards that i deal
you
fine why what does that mean
what what are you
what are you talking about
what
what
huh
okay wait oh interesting
that got pulled up into there
what's that about there's something
about that but i don't know what it is
whoa
look at the parallel look how that lines
up perfectly right there there's
something there these these candlesticks
are are perfectly aligned right there
huh
fascinating okay i i want to go for the
totem route because i need more totem
all right whoa what's that
oh
oh well i oh well okay well that i like
that card but also i didn't know that
that's what that did
i didn't know if that's what that did
fine
can't take more than three items and you
have three
perhaps you'll accept this gift from my
friend
oh
okay
a background always useful
thank you
okay
bugs can swim
that's not a good day
nice top deck thank you thank you very
much
god the ringworm what does the ringworm
do i don't know what it do
what does it do it can't do anything
whatever it's fine
nice
bad place shut up god you're so
critiquable
cretionary
all right well this is basically one
pack rat i don't even need you go
easy
not even a challenge anymore
all right cave of wonders show me your
magic
hi
trial of power okay four attack power
combined that's probably okay
three by bones
two of the future must be kin
i don't even remember what's really in
my deck but i know that i have a lot of
power
i bet i can pass this unless i get my
[ __ ] power cards oh well
god damn it
god damn it you better give me a good
totem this is not my run i can i can
tell you that this is not my run
ah can i get something okay well that's
that's expressly unhelpful
whatever
i'll go for squirrel packs
huh
[Music]
salatushins
yep
solutions i'm gonna go ahead and pull a
tooth oh my meat
cool thank you
nice
interesting
yeah
yeah okay
i win
easy
infinite cockroach uh no thank you
try again
well it's not much better i'll do the
kingfisher and then i'll merge my
uh oh i get two merges i don't know if i
have two of the same card in anything
but i definitely don't need a pack but
there is a totem up there but
[Music]
i might have two of two of two
i did unless i didn't
i did
all right i don't know if i'm gonna get
the right cards once i get this but
whatever we'll see what happens
i really don't know what this is about
there's always something secret to these
cards i know that and i get that but
also what is this about
you skip your turn
neat
oh interesting
oh interesting
interesting
ah
interesting i see
that's why it's good that's why it's
very good
oh
interesting
interesante
interstelling
i get it okay
all right so i can i can
run the gamut of trying to get a
duplicate card or i could go for this
thing
i go for the trial i'm hoping that i'm
good i don't know come on be good to me
bones
power i know i have powerful cards i
know i have powerful cards i know i just
got really bad luck that time
there we go
they're easy
easy
all right uh i have a black coat in my
deck i wonder what would happen if you
duplicate the black goats
because i do have them
come on
oh what happens i don't know
you don't want to see this
whoa that's got two health wow that's
really great that's really good
wow i'm really happy about that i'm
really happy god i'm happy i would have
rather had two black goats but whatever
you bring fresh fish
easy chews all right let's go ahead and
uh
let's go ahead and use this up
youch
we're gonna do this
put this there that's a nice emergency
black goat that's very nice
there
then we're going to
sacrifice you to get you
here to block that and then we're gonna
leave it at that for now
i'll steal hard shoes
[Music]
hold on now hold down now bubble hold on
now bubble
okay i just wanted to leave that like
that because in the next one he's gonna
go for the chum buckets
i know that's gonna happen i just wanted
to be ready for it
oh shut up you hush you
shashams
all right
this is easy easy easy choice easy
choice because it's super easy because
what's gonna happen is i'm on a win
easy choozies
bam winner time me
done
[Music]
maybe you kind of suck at this but i've
said that many times before you could
make this hard on me
reignite yeah whatever
it went kind of tv screen for a little
bit there
why did it do that
oh i love the auroboros love the rubber
orbiters wait did that carry over the
damage that it had from before
[Music]
oh
i remember that started out as like a
2-2 or a 1-1
has that just been getting stronger ever
since
interesting very interesting
extremely interesting
okay
no what i did not what oh
come on
oh did i win though
still wolf sink bug well god damn it
i didn't pick that one you [ __ ]
all right give me something good
god damn it what do i want flying
squirrels no
whatever hack squirrels
[Music]
god damn it
thorns huh
well good for you
oh that's fun
okay here we go watch this what am i
gonna do i'm gonna get the oreo or boris
out first i'm gonna beef up my auroboris
big time
put that there okay another thing
perfect get this
beehive out with that beehive then i'm
gonna kill the beehive
no
damn it i did that wrong
i'm dumb no
i'm not dumb kill that
i think i am dumb i actually think i'm
dumb no
this to put that
and put that there
and then this also
here
good play i know
i meant to do something where i could
sacrifice that and i forgot that that
was the whole crux of that so i
technically did that very wrong but
that's okay
i damn it i meant
frick god i meant to not do that okay i
didn't do this exactly how i wanted to
do it but whatever
i still won i meant to get that
auroboris actually die again so that i
could loop it all back but i i don't
know why i didn't because i thought
wrong about it but i don't know if i
could have even done it in the first
place
ah no let's reroll
pronghorn
yeah probably or elk fawn that'd be nice
give me a good totem and by good i mean
the undying one that's really what i
want
god damn it what
grown to a more powerful
what if i have more powerful squirrels
what is a more powerful squirrel i'm so
curious i'm so curious what a more
powerful squirrel would be
i'm really curious i don't know how i'm
gonna make this happen
but i'm fascinated
i'm quite fascinated okay so what i have
to do oh that's a lot of elk fun um
okay don't mind me
just gonna see what the squirrel becomes
okay
oh
i might lose this all because of this
the elder scroll
god is so not worth it
all right great good
all right the elder scroll my god let's
do
the
oro boris here
and let's splash that all the way
through you skip your turn
nice
okay so what i need to do is i need to
sacrifice the oraboris
because i want it to get stronger i'll
put you there
and then i'm gonna get the squirrel out
i wish i had an elder squirrel but
whatever it's a nice backup you know if
i run out of regular cards i could just
put squirrels out there and hope they
live not like i could draw enough but
whatever like
i thought that uh the corpses would have
already done that
let's go ahead and take care of that
thing
okay go
nice
elk
sure
bullfrog i mean the game's over i would
love to kill that again
to get it even stronger i can yes i can
because i can kill it
put it here
and then kill both of these to put it
back down easy
nice
i think that's permanent because i don't
think it started as a 3-3 last time i
think it was something completely
different
fun
hi
the trap in business has been lagging
after being defeated by that challenger
well i'm thinking of clearing the
inventory trying something else
helps her cheaper now
okay i have a lot okay i'm gonna take uh
your goldens your goldens your goldens
your goldens your goldens
okay thank you
all right i don't remember where i need
to put oh it's right up the road there
it's bleeding yields three blood if you
can ignore the bleeding
uh
i always love a good
goat
perfect
oh i forgot to oh i forgot i still have
that the elder squirrel problem
okay
okay well that's gonna fly right over
that so this pelt doesn't really do much
but i could get my ouroboros right out
right away
win it in one shot with this
uh
let's go for a
victory
or i could try to get it even stronger
in this next turn
oh but that thing would cause a problem
and then i'd i'd be two hits away and i
don't know if i would pull i would pull
a thing no i'm not gonna get group well
i'm pretty greedy
i am greedy oh why didn't i put it over
there i forgot that like you can fly
over creatures but oh i forgot that it
could still block against
or it could still attack that
well i didn't think this through
and now let's just win it i don't care
thank you have a nice
all
day
let's see what we can get
hair pelts love that this is nice
could always use another black goat but
i don't need one wolf cub is nice
wolf cup
and now for the goldies
all right geck
what's the big deal about geck strange
larva oh i could combine a child 13. i
could get a second one of these yes well
i guess uh oh i get all of them i forgot
nice thank you
and now i'm going to the mushy guy to
split to entwain
you have they're not victims
sure yeah okay
sure they're not go child 13 become an
even worse amalgamation
ah
what have we done
i don't know what did you do i wasn't
looking
all right let's see how this does i bet
this is gonna go great i bet i'm really
gonna crush it
with my super squirrels
hi again
you shouldn't have come here
still salty after me last
death
oh yeah i forgot my super
coat
all right whatever
um
well this is a lot of nothing well this
sure is a lot of nothing
okay well this is a good opportunity to
do the beehives
let me go ahead and play the smoke
first beehive there it's gonna get hit
but not die which is exactly what we're
looking for and then
what i can do in a weird way is get the
goat out there it's got a tail it's not
gonna die right off the bat
wait do i have five i guess i could
technically play that but i don't want
to also keep it in my hand all right go
team go
ow
all right well this
this is very silly oh god damn it
all right strange larva i'm really not
doing anything that's gonna get me
anywhere but whatever it's fine
go
oh right strange larva you need a
sacrifice well the bee is gonna be a
strange larvae the the bee was infected
by something and we don't really fully
understand what it was all right this is
this is the wimpiest start i've ever had
to a game
thanks for the bees
strange pupis oh come on pupis at least
it's gonna work well it's just gonna get
killed by the trap there fat a lot of
use you're gonna be
all right can i get oh my god all right
well stout man you're out for some
reason
you're a bad play you're a bad card
oh mothman mothman only has one health
mothman wait mothman's gonna die next
turn oh [ __ ]
[Music]
what is this what am i getting
this is the worst cards possible lisa's
gonna fly right over and do some sick
damage
mothman go
oh wait i forgot
oh god damn it wath bloth man you
wathable man
you man of wasp nith
oh you waspy [ __ ]
god damn it you waspy [ __ ]
let's uh get this over with then shall
we
this is terrible
this is terrible this is the worst this
is i
could not have gone worse this is
terrible this is truly something
terrible oh no
oh no
oh
i didn't realize i was gonna die that
turn god damn it god freaking damn it
freaking damn it i get the absolute
goddamn worst hand i gotta go all the
way back to the beginning oh my god eat
my ass
oh my are you kidding me
are you kidding me
god
this is marky moo f
mark moo god damn it
it's fine
it's fine
what the hell is happening
[Music]
what
knife knife what about the knife what
about the knife man in the ghillie suit
grass man
trapped and then traded are you prepared
for a fate such as that all right so
there's definitely another
there's definitely another
there's something else here i know there
is
oh i could play this again
i need a rattler
interesting okay okay what's up with
this clock 1236 what does that mean
oh
i didn't know that those are buttons
there's got to be something
wait
one two three four
one two
one two three
one two three four five
one
one two
five one two one two three four five
five one six five one one two three
one two three six one two two
three six twelve
no that's what it started as okay that's
definitely for something i'm just not
sure if it's for the clock
that's what i'm unsure about like i do
squirrel rattler
okay all right okay okay okay
okay
i know the ant queen i actually like the
ant queen and queen's a good one i think
aunt queen's good maybe i could go for
an ant deck
all right what are we getting
oh
oh my oh my that is also very good
that's also very good squirrels are card
finders that's very very good
okay squirrels are card finders
that's good
[Music]
so what that means is that i always draw
a squirrel and no matter what
i will get a card anyway it's basically
like double my value but i don't have
that many cards right now obviously so
it's not that double my value
and then
play the stink bug
but kill the stink bug so that i can put
that here
perfect
i don't have any other cars that's right
right
excellent
must speed through this now what i don't
need is more totem stuff because i
actually have it done i have it pretty
good right now i don't have a lot of
teeth right now though maybe i could go
steal some more from the skull
two
measly two probably because they did so
terribly last time i get it i get it um
pelts or guaranteed cards i'll go cards
i don't know what the blood means anyway
it's just like
you must make a different kind of choice
now two is not a specific beast but
inside the cost that you wish to pay
i would like
tubeless
rat king okay interesting
small critter approach yes please thank
you packrat thank you
very good this is going well this is
going well
baba bowie
[Music]
oh another oh [ __ ]
yeah
actually holy [ __ ] i can actually make
my bug deck oh boy
interesting
all right what could we sacrifice
i could put the pack rat on something
else the pack rat's only a mediocre card
like on its own but when it comes to
other things it's not too bad
i'm gonna go for this ant because i have
a funny feeling i'm gonna be playing it
a lot
or maybe the ant queen
because i have a funny feeling i'm gonna
be playing it a lot yeah i'm gonna go
for the ant queen make this ant queen
special
thank you
then queen's got a backpack now all
right i know my strategy it's gonna be
bug heaven
bug heaven
perfect this is how we do easy put you
there and there
pop you there
work around item boulder's not bad
perfect
miss me
i just need more uh i need like goats
and stuff to be able to sacrifice to get
more stuff out sooner and bone things
i'm gonna need bones a lot of bones
bone things perfect
that's what i needed
put you
right there and then put you right there
and then put you right there easy easy
easy easy this is how it's done the bug
stampede
the
bug
annihilation
the annihilation of the bugs
oh nine damage
okay it's gonna take some getting used
to but the bugs are gonna have it who
knows who needs who you rulies who needs
anything like that when you got bugs
oh yeah
louis uh screw you louis i don't like
any of these
i'm actually not sure what that is
oh
my god oh
that's even better no yes no yes no yes
i need the resource generation and i and
i can find that like immediately
this is what i was talking about this is
what i've always been needing yes
yes
yes uh health up we're gonna make
the cat might be good ah ant queen all
the way
easy
easy choice
this would be risky push your luck or
pull away i'm not gonna push my luck
these guys are hungry my entire
crux of my thing is based on that ant
queen i'm not gonna risk it what are you
crazy there's no way i would do that
they would eat it alive all right now i
gotta get i gotta i gotta hurry up
because i've already done this in this
episode i don't wanna i wanna get going
got any
gold in there skull let me crack it open
and take a look let me not and say you
did okay so i gotta remember that
whatever happens on this first go-around
it's gonna take all of my stuff and turn
them into gold which is not
what i want so i need someone that can
take a beating
okay you right there it's gonna turn my
cat into gold i know that but i might as
well get my wolf out because i'm going
to want to
get it right here so that it can hit
that pack mule so i can get more cards
and that's how we're going to do this
good
nice
[Music]
as long as that coyote is there we're
fine okay just going to keep pulling
these and honestly i don't need to do
anything everything's fine i took i got
the the damage done
two turns to get that done the most i
might want to do is kill
or uh have something out there to tank
the hits from
that i could just do
leave the squirrel out there i can't
replace this stoat
i ran out of cards
see i'm gonna see what i'm getting at
and then it might kill that coyote
before i'm ready for it to die
nice
plus i wanted this here to kill that
adder
bad place shut up i need more bone cards
i'm gonna grab this
the boulder right there
[Music]
nice
thank you
bone cards my mule and they're back
ain't i a stinker
okay and this round will be over
promptly right
[Music]
now
okay
let's put a coyote down i guess
okay now we're gonna get somewhere
you go there perfect
excellent what did i get bones cool
[Music]
i've drawn my entire deck okay worker
aunt
you're there blam and then squirrel
[Music]
worker ant blam boom
easy money
[Music]
ah no every kill oh yeah what did i need
to do
i've entirely forgotten what the bonus
thing was
oh
inspiring geck perhaps you can find a
use for it
oh but the oro boris but the oroboros oh
but the oraboroburos
but the oribaromi
all right i'm gonna get through this i'm
gonna get through this
i'm gonna get through this promptly and
i'm not gonna die this time
bloodhound
huh
none of these aren't particularly
inspiring
there we go that's what i'm looking for
okay and now let's do some combining
the cat's effect on the goat
ooh
what if i put the cat on the goat
make it a super oh
or i make it a super cat what do i like
more the cat or the goat i like the cat
let's not sacrifice the cat
hold on
let's sacrifice the goat and put it on
the cat i like that better that feels
better that feels a lot better i like
the cat more
oh
my god i just made a super cat
all the money i'd ever need so now i
just need big honking cards
okay
cat please yes thank you oh my god
is this really gonna work the way i
think it's gonna work because if it is
oh my god
oh my god
and watch this
oh yes yes it's totally fine watch this
let's just put the wolf down and then i
can make the over boris even stronger
oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god i wish i could do more
i wish i could do more
god that's so overpowered
that is the most overpowered thing i've
ever seen okay i don't have any
duplicates to make
oh oh i can see my deck but i got no
duplicates so that's useless to me so i
might as well just go for the cards and
then maybe get a i don't think i'm gonna
get a more interesting totem than what i
have there's very little chance of that
that's exactly what i needed this is
exactly what i needed yes yes story yes
lore floor ring the lore alarm
lore
what is that
a rabbit is created in your hand a
rabbit is defined oh you know that would
be fun but
you know i'd rather get something maybe
maybe the bug thing but i'm i'm not
gonna do that
because at the end of the day the the
card finding squirrels is just too
powerful it's even better than like the
the infinite cost squirrels you know
what i mean
okay we're gonna find uh of course we're
starting with the cat
okay rattler interesting
i suppose i could have gone for the
rattler
wait how many bones does that cost
wait what if i
there's nothing that can be hooked this
is what i'm gonna do i'm gonna get
another squirrel next time that thing's
gonna die to that i but i that's good i
need the bones and then i'm gonna unlock
those four bones and then i'm i got this
i got this
i got it guys i got it i got it i got it
i got it i also could go get my rattler
but whatever
or yeah i guess i could let me just i'm
just going to do this
this play that
i did it
oh wow
oh wow
i don't even need the bug strategy
anymore i have the bug strategy
but i don't need the bug strategy
anymore i'm just so
set for life with my aura boris and
everything
oh i guess i was gonna win anyway
[Music]
all right um
i like random random's good
infinite cat i don't need another
infinite cat that's what i don't need
kc
i don't care about the adder i don't
care about any of these
that's not the worst card i guess yeah
i'll take casey
alright let's find out what we unlocked
oh
i do relish snuffing out your excessive
candles before a boss
perhaps you will now enjoy it as much as
i do
okay
interesting
i'm not sure exactly what happened there
but
something good
okay what about this candle buddy
oh your persistence is growing quite
tiresome do you truly wish for your
skill to be masked by this cheat
how will i know if you're truly worthy
oh you know i don't know you know i
don't know you know
who knows
all right hey yeah i'm gonna increase
the power of my
[Music]
oh i should have done casey because then
i didn't
how about pushing
luck was on your
side
you sense the risk was now even greater
no i'm good
that's good i got wolf double toasty
wolf flipped over on both sides toasty
roasty i'm good dude you guys want to
talk about cheats
good god
cat please
nice
i think
[Music]
nice
eight eight for two
that's pretty good
kind of throws my whole bug strategy out
the window because i really don't need
the bugs anymore and it's kind of now
just clogging on my hand which i guess i
could go to this which i think is like a
get rid of card kind of thing but do i
really need think so
yeah whatever
you could do even more ants uh
you know i really don't have much more
that i could do
unless i wanted to get this for its
undying ability and then have something
else to sacrifice yeah let's go for that
more damage huh all right let's pop the
wolf back on there you got this buddy
yeah there you go keep it right there
sip one survivor the creature could
become more powerful
uh yeah you know i'm okay i like this
wolf six and two now that's pretty good
that's pretty good all right let's plow
through this let's plow through this
to oh greater smoke that smoke it is
great indeed
oh
you know i'm not going to complain when
you first mistook his oh yeah
yeah
yeah hey bud i'm the angler you're the
fish oh i'm only on the second boss god
i got so many so much more to go i'm
just having fun with this
i'm gonna go ahead and get the
oh abortion
because i can greater smoke
put that right there
and then i can do some more shenanigans
i don't want to do too many shenanigans
right off the bat
i'm gonna hold that thought
god there was a lot of damage
uh good luck hitting my uh oro boris
there pal
infinite
cat
oh i should have sacrificed the aurora
boris god damn it i'm dumb
ah it's fine
[Music]
nice
this is very nice
very nice
oh this is so nice love this so much
i love this so much
[Music]
i love this so oh my god
oh my god
[Music]
oh my god
all right
my cup runneth over
i'm having a delightful time i've been
having a delightful time i'm having a
goddamn delightful time i'm having a
goddamn delight
oh the oh you really ah but you know
what now i can i can take the geck and i
can find out what the hell it does
because i really don't know there's got
to be there's always something lore
related i think when it comes to these
cards that aren't like initially
valuable
or there's some hidden meaning it's got
to be rare for a reason right it's got
to be
all right there's not going to be
anything new there for a while i know
that's a signal i know that is
it's definitely a signal probably
do the cave one
i would think because i don't need more
basic cards
let's not accidentally double click okay
three sigils i do have a lot of sigils
five bones uh i don't have a lot of bone
cards i think i have more sigils than
anything maybe
that's one ah no
i already have a nice cat oh i've
already got a great cat
uh but i could put something else
unkillable there
ooh
ooh interesting
oh what happens when it goes to an even
greater warren oh that's weird
i like that
i kind of like oh then oh then i could
make maybe i could make like my oroboros
even more powerful in another turn you
know what i mean there's probably
something there there's definitely
something there
hi what's up hey guys
hey what's up guys hey how you doing hey
good to see ya good to see ya i guess i
might as well keep beefing up this wolf
all right wolf it is go wolfie
uh you know uh let's uh risk it for the
biscuit
okay we're good okay no i'm good i'm six
and six is great
uh let's go up this path
i need to go that
that sacrifice place
might be a different sacrifice though
huh it's gonna be a bit of a problem
because
those elk are gonna put the hurt on my
dudes you don't cost anything why don't
you cost anything i don't know we'll
find out
sure
i guess
let's see what happens
kind of want to see what the warren does
if given enough time
yeah let's see what happens
it could be fun
it could be fun who knows it could be
fun
could be fun
could be
might not be fun i'll find out
oh whoops i just have a squirrel out
there oh well
oops
uh oops
ah look it's an elder war and nothing
different about it i should have just
should have just done what i needed to
do a while ago
all right aurubarus it is
what we're gonna do we're gonna make it
even one more powerful than it already
is
we go
12 is nice i like 12.
when am i going to get to spend my
tifuses
because i need to i've got a lot of
tifuses that i need to spend
oh the trapper's over there well that
was dumb of me i didn't even realize
that oh i'm an idiot oh i'm dumb oh
there's not even another level where i
can use my teeth in here ah
all right um
cost for blood i have things with a lot
of health
there there you go
there you go there you go
trout pass baby
whoa i know that's not worth it now i
know it's not
i don't know i kind of like the idea of
having this there that's just fun
okay
oh this i thought oh
i thought i could do more is there
anything that i could make unkillable
that'd be valuable
immortal geck
this makes them unkillable that's why i
got it
i guess this geck would be
effectively unlimited resources because
it's free
sure
[Music]
there you go
now if only i could have put like the uh
the maturing on it
why are you always in my first hand
seems unlikely
i wasn't the smartest player i've ever
done
i just realized i didn't do that right
oh this might not have been the best
strategy
i might actually be in trouble
probably not though
definitely not
definitely not
ah no way
oh my god wait what happened whoa what
happened
oh they're flying that's right i forgot
they're flying
oh
god i
well
yeah i played that wrong i did that very
wrong attack power that's probably the
easiest one
attack power
or you could okay i was about to say i
was about to say
yeesh all right a flying cat
i mean that's pretty good but also
defensively boned i like defensive bones
okay let's uh make the auroboris cleave
let's make it a clever boris
i can't see its face all right all right
all right all right all right all right
all right all right all right all right
all right let's move let's move i'm
taking victory
all right let's let's rock this
i know i need to play this because i
really want to get all these out
[Music]
okay
do a little better this time
oh frick
oh frick
oh frick
i forgot i
oh i'm so oh my god
holy crap
oh wow i am
extremely dumb
okay
so i need my clevis boris because i'm
gonna have to kick the ass of those two
ravens i definitely need that and i need
to get that warren out of there and then
i need to block from that fawn
okay yeah all right okay we still got
this everybody hold on
okay clever boris is here
then i need to put this down to find a
card
let's do
where'd my cat go
i don't know where my cat went
[Applause]
oh god damn it i just realized how dumb
that was okay
all right here we go
[Music]
thank you
thank you
man i've been misplaying a lot a lot
okay thank you
okay there we go
that's so much overkill i'll never be
able to spend those teeth because i went
the wrong path
it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine it's fine
it's fine it's fine it's fine fine it's
fine
it's fine i don't need it well you know
rattlers are not bad
anything else
mole
okay
should have gone for the rattler
i don't think i have any duplicates
so many of those all right
don't worry about guys guys don't worry
about it it's all fine everything's fine
hey
here we go what if i put that on my
arrow oh
all right my wolf is now a defensive
wolf
easy good good good good all right let's
kill this trapper if i lose to this
trapper i'm gonna be so mad at myself
i'll never forgive myself
okay i know what i need to do i know
what i need to do no i don't no i don't
because my aura boris is
very
good it's necessary
there's my cat i couldn't find my cat
okay so i'm gonna get the cat right here
and the cat's never gonna leave that
spot and then i'm gonna put
this dude here and this dude here
and then
greater smoke greater smoke right there
perfect
grab another one of these
right
[ __ ] oh am i really dumb am i really
dumb i'm really dumb that's okay
i have to draw a regular card there good
oh not good god damn it okay it's fine
i'm in no rush why would anybody be in a
hurry here
good that's what we were looking for
anyway
okay now we can start getting into it
let's kill these two and put the wolf
there now that the path is clear we're
going to send the stinkbug
right there but before we do that we're
going to get another card
let's actually pick them right let's get
my aura boris in my hand
i'm not going to play it right now i
have to clear out some of these things
stink bug goes
actually
no the aurora boris is perfect for this
because
it literally can't die
i forgot about that
[Music]
sure
well that was easy
hope you brought pelts ah well i didn't
and it don't matter actually i'm gonna
get that adder out of the way
add her and uh
get that grizzly out of here
thank you
all right uh all right i guess i'm
sitting pretty
[Music]
god i did
there we go god damn it there we go okay
thank you
oh
my god oh my god
okay well that was easy
all right finally we're on the way to
beating this game uh properly
which is exactly what i was hoping to do
from the get-go
all right uh
i guess we go you really i guess
i'll go mole man i like the mole man
okay
okay oh
i never bought furs
i never bought any furs
god damn it
all right
all right cabin cabin cabin on let's see
where this goes let's see where this
goes let's see where this goes
full sprint full sprint full sprint i'm
going forward i'm going i'm going faster
faster what do you got what do you got
challenges
special challenges
ah boons yes boons
all right rarity i do have a lot of
rares uh pelt cards no way travel the
ring if you have a ring you
automatically pass i do not let's go for
the rears come on baby rare call yes yes
oh two out of three
success
choice of boons
magpie
i already have that
start battle with eight bones
with grand fur zone well i don't want
that i'll just do the bones thank you
see airborne swift
[Music]
i don't even know if i have any of these
i never go for these symbols i don't
think i have
those
oh my god
holy [ __ ] i got it
all right a draw twice oh my god yes
please
oh my god
i am done how buddy get ready for that
moon to get kicked in its ass
get ready for ass kicking of your life
let's go ahead and put the moon down
first go ahead and put the moon on the
ground hey pal hey leshy
i'm back sit
yes me am back with you
i can't do anything well it's like i'll
have to beat him again
now i relish this moment
excellent
[Music]
cheater
this guy cheats did you guys know that
this guy cheats
excellent
love it
oh yeah
this is not bad it's not bad
all right cool i don't like the mantis
god but whatever okay let's get this
started right here
let's get the orborus
oh i got uh well it doesn't matter where
boris can't die so
let's go for that
14 damage kind of hefty hard to deal
with
hard to block
the moon the forest bent gave rise to
shadowy figures
ah
oh wow they're in the wrong spots
they're they really chose poorly
they chose purely
wolf i guess might as well uh make my
or boris even beefier
okay
ouch that hurt
moon time
you want a moon
this ought to work again yeah don't try
anything new
all right that should take two turns
i'll just draw cards i don't even need
to do anything
pack rat
whoa what if i fishing oh i wish i could
have fishing hooked the moon
oh that would have been oh that would
have been fun
all right go for it i'm gonna kill the
moon
oh wow it hit from both directions oh my
god
oh my god
oh wow
geck go
go gekk
i forgot that it hit both oh wow you're
not the first to triumph over the moon
but go on finish it oh i will thank you
easy with the unbeatable oroborus
you had won the respect of the strange
cabin's inhabitant your body quaked as
the adrenaline of the battle subsided
leaving you with a gnawing hunger you
had not eaten for days
is it not so
give me i actually would like to eat it
this time i took extra care in preparing
it it does look delicious i do kind of
want it
does this not meet your standards very
well
not even giving me an option
hi pal
so i think what the objective is i need
to find film that's what i'm getting out
of this i need to find film for this
so that i can take a picture of him
that's my legendary camera does not
function without a loaded film role
so somewhere in this cabin is film you
are a champion and i wish to memorialize
you
please describe your name all right this
is markimoo
xxx
so there's something about the morse
code there's something about all this
the next episode that we do with this is
going to be all focused on just puzzle
solving because there's something else
here about this
yeah yeah yeah yeah uh-huh yeah uh-huh
okay there's some
what
okay
because it can't all be about this i
think this is just for like unlocking
special boons to make the games easier
it's not necessarily what it needs to be
about we'll figure it out next time
thank you everybody so much for watching
hope you're enjoying this i know i am
let me know what you thought down the
comments below and as always i will see
you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]